but this one is sort of like landing in
different shapes
and when i was saying at the beginning
of the class
centimeters
that means i don't move my hand around i
know exactly where it's going it's
almost like facing me
so
there's the hand that's facing me as
this goes down
it goes there
and then it fits
i don't believe in god but there was a
god he made this especially for this
hand to fit in
you see and i can do it without even
holding this it's um because you locked
it yeah
you can do it really quick you see
because out in the street you're gonna
have a millisecond and that's all you've
got you can't do big fancy in the dojo
we do lots of things we exercise and
because they're beautiful we do lots of
nice rooms in the street you know you've
got you've got a fast chance and you've
got to do it
so let's do it look again
so i'm looking at my
hand when it allows me to move in
it fits perfectly in
that shoulder and i can even do this
grab one gig
i can come down here for them
i can change
techniques
so there's lots of variants
to this right so let's try again but
your hand is sometimes going on the back
of the head and then you're changing it
and you haven't got time it's got to be
that's when it becomes beautiful i'm
going to get up i'm still locking down
i'm still locking the arm
so there's a whole package of what this
can do rather than what just these can
do